good morning Hank it's Tuesday so in
Sunday's US presidential debate a voter
asked what specific tax provisions will
you change to ensure the wealthiest
Americans pay their fair share in taxes
the candidates answers were interesting
but limited so today I thought I'd take
a look at Hillary Clinton and Donald
Trump's tax plans but to do that we need
to understand the current US tax system
which unfortunately is not uncomplicated
so let's imagine three married couples
with two children apiece the Johnsons
make the median US household income of
fifty two thousand dollars per year the
Kennedys make three hundred thousand
dollars per year and the Roosevelts make
a million dollars a year
definition time so your top marginal tax
rate is the tax rate you pay on your
last dollar of income for the Kennedys
that's thirty three percent but that's
not actually the percentage of their
income that goes to federal income taxes
because no matter how much money you
make your first eighteen thousand four
hundred fifty dollars of income is taxed
at 10% to the next fifty six thousand
dollars is taxed at 15% and so on in the
end the Kennedys pay about sixty six
thousand four hundred twenty four
dollars in federal income taxes under
the current system that's twenty two
percent of their income that's their
effective tax rate the Roosevelts with
their million dollars of income pay
about three hundred thirty six thousand
five hundred dollars in federal taxes an
effective tax rate of thirty three point
six percent four point seven if you want
to round up but God knows it can't be
that simple because usually families
like the Kennedys and the Roosevelts pay
less in taxes due to deductions the US
tax code allows you to deduct certain
expenses from your income like
charitable donations some retirement
savings and mortgage interest and you
can either itemize your deductions by
listing them or take the so called
standard deduction which is available to
all taxpayers for married couples filing
jointly it's currently twelve thousand
six hundred dollars okay I know this is
a little bit complicated but stay with
me lastly we have the Johnsons with
their income of fifty two thousand
dollars a year the Johnsons can expect
to pay five hundred fifty-three dollars
in federal income tax an effective tax
rate of just over one percent wait what
right so first the Johnsons take the
standard deduction of twelve thousand
four hundred dollars which brings their
taxable income down to thirty nine
thousand six hundred dollars and you
also take a $4,050 personal exemption
for yourself your spouse and your two
kids that's sixteen thousand two hundred
dollars which brings the family's
taxable in
come down to $23,200 they would pay
about twenty-five hundred fifty three
dollars of taxes on that income except
for child tax credits there is a one
thousand dollar tax credit for each
defendant child you have so that's how
the Johnsons get down to five hundred
fifty three dollars and I think this is
really important to understand because
it underscores that for the half of
American families making less than fifty
two thousand dollars a year federal
income taxes are quite low in fact a
large majority of those households pay
no federal income tax at all they do pay
lots of other taxes though like payroll
taxes which neither candidate is
proposing to change and sales and
property taxes which are local and
therefore not under the purview of the
president but it's really critical to
remember that federal income tax policy
can only do so much okay so we're going
to look at both these proposals mostly
using analysis from the Tax Foundation
which for the record is non partisan but
usually considered conservative leaning
let's start with Hillary Clinton's tax
plan which she described like this
nobody who makes less than $250,000 a
year and that's the vast majority of
Americans as you know will have their
taxes raised because I think we've got
to go where the money is and that's
accurate Clinton's plan mostly leaves
the tax code unchanged with four main
differences first income over five
million dollars per year which is
currently taxed at thirty nine point six
percent would be taxed at forty three
point six percent there's a lower tax
rate on capital gains which is like sale
have appreciated stocker of a business
and on capital gains over five million
dollars Clinton's tax plan would also
increase that rate 4% from twenty to
twenty four percent
secondly households with over a million
dollars in income would have to pay at
least a thirty percent effective tax
rate so basically they couldn't use
deductions to get under a thirty percent
tax rate third carried interest would be
taxed like regular income this is a
little bit complicated but basically
carried interest allows many investment
bankers to claim most of their income as
capital gains rather than as ordinary
income which means they pay a lower tax
rate this would close that so-called
loophole and lastly Clinton's plan would
double the child tax credit and also
introduced a new $1,200 Tax Credit for
caregivers so if you're taking care of
an elderly or disabled family member
that credit would be available to you
there would also be some changes to the
estate tax and some corporate taxes
would change in an attempt to keep us
companies from shielding their income
from US taxes so under the Clinton tax
proposal neither the Kennedys northern
Roosevelt's would see their taxes
unless the Roosevelts are claiming
hundreds of thousands of dollars in
deductions in which case their taxes
might go up slightly the Johnsons
however would see their federal income
taxes go from five hundred fifty three
dollars a year to zero because of the
increase in the child tax credit so just
to be clear at the debate when Donald
Trump said she is raising everybody's
taxes massively that's just not true for
the vast majority of Americans but there
is a cost to tax increases even when
they're only focused on the rich they
discourage investment and business
spending like the Tax Foundation says
that the Clinton plan would reduce
overall US economic output by one
percent over the long term other
projections have it much lower but
regardless it would have some effect it
would also of course create new
government revenue which would be used
to pay for subsidized college
infrastructure projects and paid family
leave most nonpartisan analyses conclude
that after accounting for all of this
the Clinton tax and budget proposals
would add about two hundred billion
dollars to the u.s. debt over the next
ten years okay let's talk about Donald
Trump's new tax plan which is quite
different from the one he released in
June in which I talked about here at the
debate he said we're cutting taxes for
the middle class and I will tell you we
are cutting a big lake for the middle
class so a transplant features three
marginal tax brackets for married
couples filing jointly income up to
$75,000 a year would be taxed at 12%
from there up to $225,000 would be taxed
at 25 percent and above $225,000 would
be taxed at 33% he would also cap
deductibles for married couples at
$200,000 a year he would make childcare
expenses deductible up to the average
cost of child care in your state
increased the standard deduction from
twelve thousand six hundred dollars per
year for married couples filing jointly
to $30,000 a year and he would get rid
of personal exemptions as you'll recall
those personal exemptions allow you to
take 4050 dollars off your income for
each member of your family eliminating
them even with the increase in the
standard deduction would mean that for
many families with single parents or
with more than three children making
between about sixty to a hundred
thousand dollars a year taxes would
actually go up somewhat under Trump's
plan this would be the case for about
7.8 million households but for the rest
of us our federal income taxes would
stay about the same or go down under
Trump's plan like if we look at our
three hypothetical families the Johnsons
would see their federal income taxes go
from five hundred fifty three dollars a
year to four hundred dollars the
kennedys making three hundred thousand
dollars a year would pay about forty six
thousand three hundred
fifty dollars in taxes a reduction of
about twenty thousand dollars from the
current system and the Roosevelts would
pay about two hundred eighty seven
thousand two hundred fifty dollars as
you can see the tax cuts are heavily
concentrated on the wealthiest
individuals who pay the most income tax
Trump's plan would also decrease the
corporate tax rate from thirty five
percent to fifteen percent and like
Clinton's plan it would seek to get back
some of the profits that are offshore
from US companies and it would close the
carried interest loophole in total
before accounting for macroeconomic
effects Trump's plan would lower
revenues somewhere between four point
four and seven point two trillion
dollars over the next ten years
depending on who's doing the math but
just as higher taxes can discourage
investment lower taxes can encourage it
and the Tax Foundation does project the
trumps plan would lead to growth but no
matter what you've heard that does not
mean that tax cuts pay for themselves
they don't
for instance both the Reagan and the
Bush tax cuts boosted growth but they
lowered federal revenues the Tax
Foundation which remember is
conservative-leaning says that even
after growth is accounted for federal
revenues will decrease under Trump's
plan between two point six and three
point nine trillion dollars now Trump is
proposed to pay for some of this
shortfall around 1 trillion dollars over
ten years by a budget cuts but he also
wants to spend about five hundred
billion dollars more on the military
over the next ten years so even the
rosiest projections have Trump's total
budget and tax plan adding about two
trillion dollars to the national debt
over the next ten years that's ten times
greater than under Clinton's plan and
other projections like those made by the
Tax Policy Center have that number at
seven point two trillion dollars
thirty-six times greater than Clinton's
plan I want to pause for a second to
discuss why this could be such a huge
problem so currently the u.s. is debt
held by the public is about seventy
seven percent of our total annual
economic output that's high but it's not
so high that people are worried about
our ability to pay it back we know that
because interest rates on Treasury bills
are near zero
it's basically seen as a guaranteed that
the United States will pay its debt but
if our publicly held debt to GDP ratio
gets higher traditionally when it gets
to a hundred percent or 110 percent that
might change lenders might start to get
nervous and think maybe the US can't pay
its debts which would make loans to the
United States government riskier which
would make them more
expensive interest rates would go up to
pay for the more expensive loans the
government would have to increase taxes
or decrease spending which would inhibit
growth which would lead to lower tax
revenues that would necessitate taking
out more loans with higher and higher
interest rates which would leave less
money for programs like Social Security
and unemployment insurance which would
further inhibit growth which would will
were government revenues and pretty soon
Greece this is called a debt spiral and
it is a catastrophe that once it starts
is very difficult to stop it often takes
decades to unwind now the chances of a
debt spiral in the United States are
very low no matter who becomes president
but the nonpartisan committee for a
responsible federal budget has the
10-year debt from Trump's tax plan
rising to one hundred five percent of
GDP and that is a very scary level now I
want to emphasize that there are serious
and thoughtful Republican tax and budget
plans out there but to cut taxes by the
amount that Trump is proposing it is
necessary to either cut popular
entitlement programs like Medicare or
else to cut defense spending
dramatically serious Republican budget
proposals do one or both and Trump's
does neither
so in summary Donald Trump's tax plan
would cut income taxes for most
Americans with the majority of the
benefits going to the wealthiest
households and small increases on taxes
for some middle-class families Hillary
Clinton's tax proposals would cut income
taxes for middle class families with
children the rest of us probably
wouldn't see much change but the
wealthiest American households would
have their taxes go up if you'd like
much more information there are links to
nonpartisan analyses in the doobly-doo
below I'll also try to be in comments to
answer any of your questions and if you
are yet registered to vote or aren't
sure if you're registered please go to
youtube.com slash how to vote in every
state and find your state in many states
the registration deadline is today so
register please vote hank dftba I will
see you on Friday